ce n'est pas le député le plus suivi sur
Tik Tok mais c'est sans doute celui que
les influenceurs redoutent le plus car
dans ce domaine comme dans les autres
mon invité à appliquer sa propre méthode
avec sérieux et application
[Musique]
bonjour Arthur de Laporte bonjour alors
quand on lit les portraits qui vous sont
consacrés il y a des formules qui
reviennent élèves modèles tête bien
faite brillant et puis il y a cette
expression qui a été employée par
Laurence Dumont Laurence Dumont c'était
la députée socialiste sortante qui vous
a un peu transmis sa circonscription si
l'on peut dire on va on va en parler et
vous a qualifié de gens de idéal comment
est-ce que vous le prenez ce que c'est
un compliment ou est-ce que ça vous
agace venant de Laurence c'est toujours
positif parce que c'est
j'apprécie énormément dans cette
expression il y a l'idée d'un jeune
homme presque trop parfait qui offre
très peu de d'aspérité et du coup qu'on
a un peu du mal à saisir à cerner alors
j'ai envie de vous dire aidez-moi Arthur
de la porte qui êtes-vous qui suis-je
c'est une question à El Kabbale répondez
je suis donc député de la deuxième
circonscription du Calvados depuis 6
mois mais avant j'étais chercheur voilà
c'est chercheur
[Musique]
parce que c'est l'expression d'une forme
de curiosité permanente surtout sur le
monde et la volonté aussi de sortir on
va dire du discours préconçu ou de ce
qu'on impose au réel pour analyser des
phénomènes analyser des choses et
toujours prendre un peu de recul par
rapport à une image un peu lisse ou de
façade qui serait parfois trompeuse et
si je dis si je précise que vos deux
parents étaient instituteurs que vos
quatre grands-parents étaient
instituteurs est-ce que ça aide à
répondre à cette question et ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est déterminant
pour vous disons que j'ai grandi dans un
milieu où on va dire l'éducation au sens
large était importante mais c'est une
égalité populaire c'est une éducation à
la citoyenneté c'est une éducation
finalement au monde qui nous entoure est
toujours voilà cette idée de la
curiosité et on va dire à une certaine
forme voilà d'optimisme par rapport aux
choses c'était une éducation qui était
aussi sur des nouvelles méthodes de
pédagogiques c'est pas le côté
j'apprends mes devoirs je récite Malson
mais c'est toujours je fais des
expériences je mène des projets et on
apprend aussi par la découverte alors
vos parents n'avaient pas d'engagement
politique direct mais tous les étés il
vous emmenaient dans les campings
autogérés de la de la MAIF un peu façon
qui booste on va dire vous avez aussi
fait votre première manif à l'âge de 4
ans il y a même un article voilà on le
voit ici le petit bonhomme en rouge à
côté de la poussette c'est vous plus
tard vous êtes devenu un peu le géo du
lycée vous avez été le président du
Foyer vous avez créé une radio vous avez
créé aussi un journal est-ce que vous
faites le lien entre tout ça et votre
engagement politique futur c'est sûr que
quand on est amené à s'engager on va
dire dans la vie de la cité par voilà
différentes formes de toujours essayer
d'animer un collectif on finit aussi par
se dire qu'est-ce que je peux moi
apporter et quand on voit la politique
moi j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
politique je me suis dit bah oui c'est
peut-être l'une des étapes qui arrivent
quand on a voilà dynamisé des collectifs
toute sa jeunesse ce que j'ai finalement
pris beaucoup de plaisir à parce que
c'était toujours un esprit de solidarité
comment on va vers les autres enfin il y
a quand même cette dimension là puis
alors il y a votre éveil à la politique
votre conscientisation qui s'est faite
très jeune à l'âge de 10 ans vous avez
épluché toutes les professions de fois
des des candidats à la présidentielle et
vous avez décidé de voter
à l'époque c'est vrai que c'était un
choix un peu marginal ça l'est peut-être
un peu resté mais c'est vrai que moi je
j'avais regardé les différentes
professions de fois et je trouvais que
son programme était celui qui me parlait
le plus après voilà on a été évidemment
déçu triste et traumatisé par la défaite
de Lionel Jospin enfin c'est resté comme
quelque chose d'extrêmement marquant
mais aussi jeune quoi oui alors après on
parlait toujours de politique autour de
moi c'est vrai que c'est ce milieu on va
dire ce qu'on appelle le milieu partisan
du Parti socialiste en sociologie
politique c'est des enseignants qui sont
investis voilà dans dans l'éducation
populaire et qui vont parfois en camping
l'été c'est vrai et notamment dans des
campings où on élit les responsables de
camp qui sont propriétés de la
collectivité donc ça c'est intéressant
si on regarde votre trajectoire après en
ça ressemble un peu presque un parcours
sans faute du côté des études d'abord
donc vous avez fait Normal Sup à Lyon en
même temps que si on se trouve à Paris
et vous êtes devenu agrégé d'histoire et
puis dans votre trajectoire politique
vous avez été collaborateur de députés
vous avez été ensuite collaborateur de
la présidente du groupe PS Valérie rabot
ensuite patron de la fédération PS du
Calvados puis enfin député et
porte-parole du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale ça donne
l'impression de quelque chose de très
méthodique très rationnelle dans votre
ascension politique comme si vous aviez
fixé des démarches à gravir une par une
je sais pas si c'est des marches à
gravir une par une parce qu'il y a aussi
des histoires de rencontres voilà quand
j'étais quand je me suis engagé aux
participer j'ai pris ma carte en 2013 au
moment du mariage pour tous déjà
tobirats je me suis dit tiens je vais
m'engager pour lutter contre l'extrême
droite entre cette espèce de
droitisation permanente du débat public
et mener un peu la bataille et il
s'avère que en même temps j'ai cherché à
faire un stage et c'est après un refus
de l'orange Dumont qui connaissait pas
Yann gallud député du Cher qui a accepté
de me prendre avec lui et on était
engagé donc un collectif qui s'appelait
à gauche forte dont l'idée c'était
vraiment de dénoncer finalement et
d'être fier de se dire je suis de gauche
je défends des valeurs et donc de
dénoncer le rassemblement national ça ça
a été le facteur de mon engagement et
après de fil en aiguille on fait on fait
des rencontres on fait des rencontres
mais il y a quand même ce côté
méthodique et sérieux chez vous qui
ressort c'est ce qui peut en ressortir
derrière je dirais pas que voilà je suis
pas sérieux mais je pense que la
politique aussi on peut prendre de la
distance par rapport à ça et c'est des
choses sérieuses mais soi-même on peut
voilà ne pas toujours l'aide dans son
rapport aux gens et vous pouvez laisser
un peu de place au hasard quand même ça
vous arrive moi c'était pas sûr que si
tu allais se passer c'est juste que de
fil en aiguille il y a une Galu connaît
quelqu'un fait une rencontre me dit
tiens
elle aimerait bien te prendre comme
collaborateurs bon ben du coup je bosse
et puis on se connaît on se rend compte
je rencontre Valérie Rabault c'est
plutôt une affaire de rencontre il y a
autre chose qui m'a marqué c'est que
votre formation de chercheur en histoire
vous l'avez aussi méthodiquement
associée à votre engagement politique
d'une certaine façon quand j'ai
découvert vos sujets de recherche j'ai
pas pu m'empêcher de sourire parce que
vous avez commencé par un mémoire qui
était consacré au voyage de François
Mitterrand à Sofia vous avez fait une
thèse qui est consacrée à la
recomposition des courants au sein du PS
vous avez aussi étudié la façon dont la
série Baron Noir qui est consacrée au PS
a été perçu par les militants les
responsables du parti socialiste et puis
alors vous évoquez il y a une Galu vous
avez été son directeur de campagne au
législatives dans le Cher quand vous
avez pris ces fonctions vous avez décidé
de faire un petit travail de recherche
sur la Fédération pèse dans le
département
c'est ça veut dire quoi ça c'est ça veut
dire que finalement la politique c'est
quelque chose qui est chronophage et
donc moi j'aimais aussi beaucoup la
recherche et j'avais un matériau sous
les yeux qui était pass je veux dire le
Parti socialiste c'est quelque chose qui
me questionnait à la fois en tant que
militant mais aussi en tant que
chercheur c'était des moments de
recomposition essentielles et quand je
suis arrivé dans cette organisation je
ne comprenais pas tout j'avais pas les
codes et faire de la recherche c'était à
la fois un moyen de comprendre cette
histoire c'est de culture et puis
c'était aussi un moyen de gagner du
temps pour faire de la recherche et en
même temps de la politique parce que moi
quand j'étais par exemple avec Anne
Gallu bah oui j'étais sur les routes du
matin au soir mais le midi je m'arrêtais
chez un militant je faisais une un
entretien je passais le soir au siège du
Parti socialiste j'ai exploré les
archives de la Fédération vous voyez ça
permettait en fait de faire les deux
d'être à la fois militant le jour où la
nuit et puis chercheur le jour où la
nuit et voilà un vrai évoquer maintenant
votre activité en tant que député je
sais pas si Maëva gaina Nabilla ou Seb
la frite regarde LCP mais il y a un
député dont il connaissent à mon avis le
nom c'est vous vous êtes à l'origine
d'une loi qui a donné des sueurs froides
aux influenceurs
regardez
alors on est là pour vous raconter
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale légalis alors vu ma tête et
mes expressions du visage on vous dit
bien que ça ne s'est pas très bien passé
pour moi pourquoi ils m'ont demandé si
j'avais déjà fait des produits pour des
placements de produits pour les paris
sportifs oui pour la chirurgie
esthétique oui crypto trading oui je
vous dis la vérité je me suis sentie
tellement honteuse
on aurait dit que c'était mes pères
donc là c'était melana est une
influenceuse qui a quand même je crois
un million d'abonnés sur Instagram et
que vous avez reçu à l'Assemblée dans le
cadre de cette proposition de loi que
vous aviez porter avec Stéphane Végéta
et qui a été adopté proposition de loi
sur les influenceurs vous l'avez trop
baptisé cette pauvre
oui après je peux vous dire que on n'a
pas été méchant c'est juste qu'on
voulait comprendre ce qui se passait et
donc de discuter avec des influenceuses
c'est ça fait partie en fait du parcours
de la loi et quand on l'a dit on a cette
dérive là est-ce que ça vous est arrivé
elle a dit oui oui donc à la fin il a
dit je suis une repentie bon tant mieux
moi je trouve que c'est bien qu'elle est
pris conscience qu'elle avait fait des
choses qui avaient conduit à des dérivés
normes et des influenceurs c'était mis
plein les poches mais encore une fois
c'est c'est minorité ces influenceurs
qui c'est ceux qui sont issus de la
télé-réalité notamment mais qui voilà on
fait un peu n'importe quoi aujourd'hui
l'idée de la loi c'était d'arrêter avec
l'absence de cadre et de remettre un peu
d'ordre là dedans je pense qu'on va y
arriver et je pense que il y a une prise
de conscience chez melanight mais pas
seulement plus largement chez les
influenceurs je peux vous dire que Maëva
gaynam par exemple quand regarder votre
jour elle a fait une story où elle
montre que elle découvre la Lamande qui
est faite donc ça peut être jusqu'à
300.000 euros d'amende et là il fait oh
comme ça un petit mouvement de recul ben
oui c'est vrai vous êtes connecté aux
influenceurs cette loi je les disais
vous l'avez coécrit avec le député
Renaissance Stéphane vogeta le début de
cette législature était marqué par des
tensions très fortes entre les députés
de la majorité et ceux de l'opposition
et alors vous vous faites copain copain
avec un député de la majorité pour faire
voter une loi à l'unanimité quand même
dans cette hémicycle très tendue c'est
c'est quoi c'est votre côté géo du lycée
qui ressort ou alors je peux vous dire
que c'est pas fini les tensions
aujourd'hui encore on a des tensions et
je suis le premier à m'opposer au
gouvernement sa politique
d'atrophisation du débat démocratique
mais ce qu'on a voulu montrer ce que
j'ai voulu montrer c'est qu'il y avait
une autre méthode qui était possible une
méthode où le Parlement il reprenait son
pouvoir et oui se saisissait des sujets
moi j'ai commencé j'ai déposé mon texte
fin décembre et derrière j'ai été
contacté notamment par Stéphane vogeta
qui m'a dit mais moi je travaille sur le
sujet est-ce que ça vous aurez une
travaille en force et bon il s'avère que
le gouvernement avait plutôt envie de
soutenir Stephen vogita et on a réussi à
montrer que on pouvait travailler
majorité comme opposition sans partir
forcément du même point de départ mais
qu'on pouvait converger par le dialogue
par la discussion et par le respect
mutuel on va passer à notre quiz après
présent vous avez droit à un quiz
spécial un quiz vous allez dresser un
palmarès des meilleurs influenceurs de
l'Assemblée je précise il s'agit de
juger les prestations des députés sur
les réseaux sociaux pas forcément dans
l'hémicycle on commence avec la
catégorie boss de la punchline le ou la
député qui vous impressionne le plus sur
les réseaux sociaux alors moi celui qui
a les meilleurs punchlines à l'Assemblée
et qui devrait être encore plus fort sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est Boris Vallot
mon président de groupe il a un sens de
la formule je peux aussi
corporate et en même temps je peux vous
dire que il est capable de sortir des
punchlines 10 à la minute c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut qu'ils continuent à travailler
un peu plus
on a ensuite la catégorie roi ou reine
lutte du LOL l'humour c'est quand même
important en politique celui qui rigole
beaucoup est sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est Adrien cloué c'est un député
insoumis et vous pouvez regarder il fait
souvent des petites vidéos comme ça et
là une capacité à prendre de la distance
par rapport au quotidien et a finalement
faire rire les gens qui est assez forte
donc voilà Adrien enfin the dock of Tik
Tok le ou la députée le plus pédago si
l'on peut dire c'est important la
pédagogie en politique moi j'aime
beaucoup évidemment ma collègue
écologiste Marie-Charlotte Guérin je
trouve qu'elle fait des vidéos sur Tik
Tok qui sont très pédago vous-même vous
y êtes essayé voilà disons que j'en fais
aussi voilà je pense que Tik Tok c'est
un média super intéressant pour aller
vers les jeunes et leur montrer
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un sablé dans les
coulisses de derrière et finalement
déconstruire un peu les idées reçues
tout en valorisant aussi l'institution
au sens large parce que c'est un bel
objet démocratique qui est
malheureusement en ce moment un peu trop
dévoyé merci beaucoup Arthur de la porte
d'être venu dans la politique et moi
[Musique]